bellissimo
[Musica]
[Risate]
tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovo
video sono parigi oggi facciamo
trattiamo un argomento
contattero nessuna come cazzo di cosa
semplicemente vi ricordate video di
master casa
alleori sì perché era una bomba
incredibile la palin ha fatto che
probabilmente faremo altre cose insieme
con marzo gratuitamente inizio divertito
un sacco spero anche lui così tanto
questo video è sempre montato da massa
che da matteo da masters ass quindi se
vedete delle chicche sue perché non sono
io non sono in grado di fare quelle cose
volevo raccontarvi un attimo di questa
esperienza perché noi mentre stavamo lì
a registrare il cameraman che appunto il
video se non l'avete visto il parlamento
trovati descrizione io ho potuto in
qualche modo vedere con i miei occhi
come funzionano gli effetti speciali ce
l'avevo già vista la partita essendo
molto appassionato di tutto questo ogni
volta che mi trovo davanti un green
screen new york volo cioè io già adesso
bucando screen nella mia testa
[Musica]
quindi poter creare un qualcosa che si
chiamasse qassimi casa come cose ho
detto facciamo questo video ed avete
apprezzato tantissimo vabbè normale
perché invito incredibile me lo
aspettavo tutto questo good feedback
quindi tra tanto vi ringrazio e
ringrazio anche marca che sta montando
il video
però volevo raccontarvi un paio di
aneddoti sostanzialmente durante le
riprese perché tutto questo è stato
girato in in un metro quadro
grease che il piccolissimo
scientifica
immaginate se su cristiana avesse uno
studio con griffin che cosa potrebbe
fare
[Musica]
non vedo l'ora di poter partecipare a
una produzione del magari c'è un po più
di spazio e gli strumenti per poter
appunto fare magie
signori il cinema
infine perché se la magia che avete
visto è uscita fuori uscita fuori con
niente scotch
ragazzi questa cosa fa veramente male
perché lo scotch riprende anche il
cervello però benvenuto nella mia vita
io sai perché la gente nemmeno giusto i
tumori e di fatto è che si metteva
rimandare la maschera il suono scotch
i greens king piccolissimo vabbè che il
cinema è tutto scotch e anche se ne
stesse cose
ma fra me lo disse una volta qualcuno
sul set del cinema è tutto scotch e
accrocchi ok che sogno
però comunque gli strumenti sono
importanti
[Musica]
dicevamo un peeling rating piccolissimo
teoretica parere
è riuscito a fare lo zio di tutto quindi
complimenti master cast è stata una
spinta incredibile
leggermente trasformando il master
castro ha dato alcune scene sono state
girate tipo non avevamo il binario
giustamente e quindi alcune scene sono
state fatte dove una persona teneva la
camera sarà su una sedia su una sedia
qualcuno spingeva tipo così si
riprenderà così che ci siamo inventati
due binari è stato incredibile comunque
ragazzi questa è stata sicuramente una
delle esperienze più belle a livello
youtube ico di collaborazione intendo di
sempre
[Musica]
mi un bel sasso
votalo si è quindi io mi sono molto
divertito speriamo di farne un'altra io
ringrazio di cuore masterclass per
averci messo tutta la sua anima stasera
perché so bene cosa significa fare video
per passione quindi so quanto si è
soddisfatti di un risultato quando si è
dato il massimo ok e io sono super super
contento e su personale che esaltano e
vuole fare un'altra cosa del genere
quindi ragazzi spero che vi sia piaciuto
questa backstage di cameraman che ripeto
se non avete ancora visto video
descrizione trovate se non sapresti
iscrivetevi anche il cane di master cast
e noi come sempre ci vediamo al prossimo
video sei grandi difetti di speciali
quick step di metterla luce qua
vediamo se funziona non ne sono sicuro
e
che ha
[Musica]
a un
sasso